the credentials of our speaker are
impressive he was born in hungry under
the Soviet occupation his family fled
from there in 56 when the great
hungarian uprising one of the most
inspiring and one of the most tragic
things ever to happen in the history of
tyranny came about this event was
formative in the life of Peter schramm
he remembers that his mother and his
father had a terrible time deciding
whether to flee or not how bad is it
going to be here what would it be like
to go to a whole new country and they
settled the dispute he recalls by asking
him ten years old and he has a character
liked one mr. Robinson just displayed
hey go for it he loves the story of the
broadcasting over the radio of the
Declaration of Independence being read
over and over again there's the Soviet
troops and tanks were closing down the
last radio station and he tells stories
of this kind better than anyone I've
ever heard the Strand family went to
California you guys he didn't speak a
word of English graduated high school
and he got his bachelor's in his
master's and his PhD and his and another
masters his MA and his PhD are from the
claremont graduate school his other mas
from the london school of economics and
political science he was the president
of the claremont institute and chief
among its founders he worked for ronald
reagan dan department of education he
moved to Ashland where he has been a
massive force for 17 years now I think
something like that he's a professor of
political science he's the founder of
their master's degree program
is the executive director of the
ashbrook center you can't explain his
achievements from his resume lots of
people come from Hungary lots of people
get PhDs they don't do what this man has
done I have some ability to speak on the
subject of how he's done it because next
year I will pass my 40th year in
friendship with him call a man of such a
character as Peter SRAM a friend is a
life-changing privilege please welcome
I think that was a wonderful
introduction you can see why his
president of a college lies well thank
you very much for having me
congratulations to your graduates
congratulations to your parents and of
course to your teachers those teachers
have helped you find your mind and also
free your mind from some passions and
interest but most importantly from some
mind forged manacles I am honored to be
here actually honored to be here because
I hold this exceptional school in eyes
the respect and regard I admired the
excellence of your curriculum and the
things for which you stand virtue and
wisdom I will of course say nothing in
Latin because that would be embarrassing
and because of what you purpose of who
you are and what you represent in this
goodly frame the world I'm also humbled
to be here as my heart is filled with
gratitude for the opportunity to talk
about liberty and learning in front of
such an August audience and I don't
exclude dr. Arnn from that although I
must admit that when the good dr.
Calvert your headmaster asked me to join
you I accepted his kind offer with
apprehension for it became increasingly
clear in our conversation that what he
wanted from a commencement speaker was
about 12 minutes worth of wisdom or
another way of putting it said just say
something like for Gettysburg addresses
this put me at ease we all know that
souls have to be tested and fear needs
to be overcome so to paraphrase Lincoln
I had a month to chop down a tree I
decided to spend 27 days sharpening my
axe
encourage a period until Here I am your
liberal arts education has focused
around the free and just society and
helped cultivate the intellectual and
personal habits necessary for
self-government this is no small matter
it might be said that your potential for
adulthood and citizenship have become
actual because while a liberal education
is a good in and of itself it also makes
you useful for any common as is obvious
given your resumes and where you're
going any calling including being a good
citizen and being a good citizen in this
exceptional country it's worth a great
good in a noble obligation
self-government is a hard thing it is in
this country where the freedom of your
mind is directly connected to political
freedom and in this country only Mark
Twain praised Americans for being
invented indeed he said the greatest
invention is freedom our greatest
invention is freedom the founders in a
gremlin can agree with this you have had
conversations with the greatest books of
the west and by this i mean the greatest
minds and you may even have made friends
with them going back to them from time
to time asking them to consider or
reconsider some point having to do with
the true or the good or the beautiful
certainly it will also do this in the
future because once you get ahold of
that conversation you will not be able
to let it go I think you know this
already your mind will always be
captivated by Booker T Washington's
argument for excellence and the
conditions of freedom or Jane Austen's
eloquent interpretation of love and
friendship where why the Great King Lear
was unable to perpetuate the seemingly
perfect political monarchy or John
Milton's gripping poetic explanation of
the origin and causes of evil
or why Mark Twain has the resourceful an
entirely American Hank Morgan doing the
Middle Ages into what effect you also
have had the opportunity to contemplate
America's ancient faith by considering
what the founders asserted in the first
paragraph of Federalist one here Publius
in trying to persuade New Yorkers to
ratify the Constitution claims that
nothing less than the founding of a new
order of the ages at stake Novus Ordo
seclorum morning was an attempt at humor
not ratifying the Constitution would be
considered excuse me not right of
hanging the Constitution would be
considered a general misfortune of
mankind because what we are doing here
what the framers did then and what we
are doing now and what future
generations of us will continue to do is
in their words in puglia TSA's words is
to decide the important question whether
societies of men are really capable or
not of establishing good government from
reflection and choice or whether they
are forever destined to depend for their
political Constitution on accident and
force in other words not only is the
existence of the union at stake in
ratifying the Constitution as well as
the security and welfare of its parts
and the fate of an empire in many
respects movie it says the most
interesting in the world but the
question of self-government itself is
also at stake can ordinary human beings
govern themselves you know the farmer
the tailor the mender of bad shoes your
mother your father your brother or
sister your rough uncle into gracious
and are they is capable of governing
themselves as those old world
aristocrats are kings who claimed the
right to govern all others because they
Warren booted and spurred while the rest
of us were born with saddles on our
backs these Americans at our Genesis
claimed and this is the basis of what
it's called American exceptionalism
claimed them the basis of universal
natural right and natural rights
according to the law of nature and
nature's God that while ordinary men
were not angels if then of course
government wouldn't be necessary there
certainly were good enough to govern
themselves this is the way George
Washington put it when he was asked
whether he was a bit confused about
republican government did he think that
men were angels no he said I just think
they're good enough to govern themselves
if good government had ever existed in
the past that was always the result of
accident and even a good and just
Willard found it impossible to
perpetuate that political order because
he thought that rule and virtue were
found in blood he assumed his children
would also rule and as well as he he
thought really that it was just a matter
of blood but of course what happened is
that his sons turned out different
directions and they all became tyrannic
in one form or another so the regime
change and that change was always
violent again the strongest came to rule
but these original Americans insisted as
a matter of self-evident truth of
equality that human beings can indeed
found a new political society on
reflection and choice
since all men are by nature equal and
free no man has a right to rule another
without his consent as meant by nature I
would write the rule over their dogs I
was going to say dogs or cats but you
all know we can't move over cancel that
confuses the argument if you don't know
what I mean by that read Kipling cat
that walked by himself in all places are
alike to write a note in passing the
stunning point that although men have a
natural right to self-government the
first thing these American founders of
ours did was to limit even that
government to certain purposes and no
other hence they divided the rulers the
majority's the people's power through
something called the Constitution this
was an attempt to try to make sure in
Jefferson's words that it was understood
that the majority only had a right to
rule to the extent it was reasonable it
was not the will of the majority that he
found interesting but rather their
reason their reflection and choice men
now understood that they would rule and
be ruled in turn and each for a certain
limited time each majority securing the
rights of all not only its own interest
the Americans invented a new form of
politics the politics of freedom this
was clear by the election of 1800 mm
Lincoln gave one lecture you know what I
mean by that instead of talking thinking
out loud he read what he wrote and he
was didactic about it even at a lectern
he only gave it a few times because it
didn't scour yes I am going to refer
especially to the one called the second
lecture on discoveries and inventions
and although there is another call the
first lecture on discoveries and
invention it's probably just part of
this one so I'm going to ignore for now
and scholars disagree about whether
those two lectures are separate or not
so I stick to the second lecture and
discoveries and invention and just point
to one thing in it the rest of it is
very interesting to read
I think this lecture is a fine piece of
thinking and writing from our least
educated president he considers the
nature of language why speech is natural
or the gift of God why human beings have
language because the original impulse of
our nature he argues is the inclination
to exchange the thoughts with one
another he also asserts that something
is missing and that something is writing
writing and that is an invention writing
is an invention in Lincoln calls it the
greatest invention of the world and he
further argues that the invention of
printing coming along some three
thousand years after the invention of
writing helped cause a great change in
human affairs until writing was attached
to printing those who could read were
the few and they cultivated that thought
that partly because of this they were
superior to the others who could not
read the printing press made possible
the dissemination of books and
eventually books got into the hands of
those who heretofore had been told they
were incapable of this mystery Lincoln
argues and I quote it is very probable
lincoln says almost certain that the
great mass of men at that time were
utterly unconscious that their
conditions or their minds were capable
of improvement they not only looked upon
it still Lincoln and not only looked
upon the educated fewest superior beings
but they suppose themselves to be
naturally incapable of rising to
equality let me repeat that it's I think
it's shocking not the way we talk
anymore is it they not only looked upon
the educated few as superior beings but
they suppose themselves to be naturally
incapable of rising to equality to
emancipate the mind Lincoln continues to
emancipate the
mine from this false an underestimate of
itself is the great task which printing
came to the world to perform before
credit Lincoln argues the slavery of the
mind was strong and it took quite a
while and I'm quoting again to break its
shackles and to get a habit of freedom I
looked it is in this connection a
curious fact lincoln says that a new
country is most favorable almost
necessary to the emancipation of thought
and the consequent advancement of
civilization in the arts unquote you
know where this is going republican
government is dependent on human nature
and human right and the self knowledge
of ordinary human beings that they don't
have sandals on their backs that thought
both their conditions and their minds
are capable of improvement that should
not surprise us that abraham lincoln's
father was a a poor farmer scratch
farmer and abraham lincoln decided that
he did not want to do that anymore on
his 21st birthday and he left and never
saw his father again
we back up for emphasis if you don't
mind republican government is dependent
on human nature and human right and the
self knowledge of ordinary human beings
that they don't have saddles on their
backs that both their conditions and
their minds are capable of improvement
indeed let the mind immersed in the
liberal arts the arts of free men and
those mines those men will establish a
habit of freedom of thought and will
come to understand as you graduates have
that they are capable of rising to the
level of equality demanded by self
government so the political Dark Ages
end with this new land rising as a city
upon a hill arguing with manly eloquence
in favor of human nature and human right
in favor of the apple of gold and the
picture of silver in favor of the
metaphysical freedom of the mind and
arguing that it is connected to the
political freedom of this new order of
the ages where ordinary human beings
rule one another who reflection rather
than force this leads to good government
and it is by design rather than by
accident and force and therefore we you
and all of us will be held responsible
for its perpetuation in this
rough-and-tumble world were force and
fought fraud still ruled I wondered that
Abraham Lincoln called us gods almost
children people some task Hillsdale
Academy has helped you find your mind
and establish those habits of freedom
necessary for self-government you now
know what Lincoln meant by saying as I
would not be a slave so I would not be a
master and you know why huck and jim
became friends on a raft and why there
they feel mighty free and easy
that you will prosper in this new world
I have no doubt as you will keep proving
to the world that free men can be
prosperous but I also know you will have
enough virtue get hold of the
conversation again about freedom and
friendship and wisdom and may you
continue to reflect and deliberate and
choose as you appreciate how the
opportunity of being a good citizen this
exceptional country is both of great
good in the noble obligation
congratulations to you and thank you